good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 2884 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures as of the 1st of September
2015 a total of 84 foundation personnel
are embedded in the United Kingdom
National Crime Agency British security
industry association and associated
security organizations in the United
Kingdom these personnel are to carry out
the following directives promotion of
mass surveillance in the United Kingdom
and legislation supporting an increase
in the installation of video
surveillance equipment in urban areas
identification of instances of scp-2401
and SCP 2884 to notification of mobile
task force theta 11 Big Brother in the
case of confirmed sightings instances of
scp-2401 or SCP 2884 to investigation to
any and all possible connections to the
individual group or entity known as the
overseer all confirmed instances of
scp-2401 or to be removed and
subsequently replaced with a suitable
form of standard video surveillance
equipment all instances of SCP 2884 2
are to be captured if possible and held
at secure facility m84 sylvia's
cardboard and paper limited pending
transfer to sites 6 - 3
description SCP 2884 is a phenomenon
affecting developed areas within the
United Kingdom SCP 2884 exhibits no
identifiable pattern in the location or
rate of its manifestation other than an
increased probability of manifestation
in areas with relatively high crime
rates SCP 2884 1 our CCTV cameras which
appear in areas affected by a CP 2884
instances of a CP 2884 1 appear only in
locations outside of the view of
pre-existing video surveillance
equipment often in excessive number
proximity and in seemingly illogical
configurations and this is a log of
notable SCP 2884 1 configurations 5
instances radially arranged on a
telephone pole at around average head
height 9 instances observing different
sections of a children's playground
three of which observe the sandbox 26
instances arranged on the wall of a
residential apartment complex each
facing a seemingly random direction two
instances one meter apart facing each
other
33 instances on the wall of an alleyway
all focused on a graffito of a home
television set in white spray paint on
the opposite wall text on the screen
reads who's watching you
examination of instances of scp-2401
suggests that they have been installed
in a standard manner by persons unknown
despite instances having been observed
in locations that would be extremely
difficult to reach by conventional means
while it is known that the installation
or appearance of instances of scp-2401
generally occurs between the hours of
9:00 p.m. and 5:00 a.m. the exact moment
of this occurrence has yet to be
observed by foundation personnel or
standard video surveillance equipment
instances of scp-2401 appear to function
with no visible power source disassembly
has revealed that instances are
constructed of a combination of standard
commercially available electronics and a
number of components of unknown origin
some non-standard components are
engraved with an image of a human eye
instances of scp-2401 cease functioning
upon disassembly and if so far remained
non-functional thereafter
despite meticulous reassembly SCP 2884 2
are a collection of humanoid entities
instances of a CP 2884 2 are physically
and genetically identical and do not
display even slight variation in height
weight build or skintone instances lack
fingerprints hair reproductive organs
and eyes the ocular cavities of
instances are hollow and shows signs of
surgical removal of the ocular organs
instances are invariably found wearing
identical dark blue riot gear and
helmets atop each instances helmet is a
mounted CCTV camera similar to instances
of a CP 2884 one specialized cabling
connects this camera directly to the
brain stem of an SCP 2884 to instance
via the back of the neck allowing the
instance a sense of sight through the
device the means by which this nervous
system interface is achieved is not
fully understood
instances of a CP 2884 to appear in an
area when an instance of scp-2401
observes a perceived criminal act
instances appear in groups of 2 to 10 in
the nearest location not under immediate
observation by nearby individuals or
video equipment with the exception of
SCP 2884 1 and will then proceed to
punish the offender forms of punishment
include partial or complete removal of
articles of clothing from the offender's
person assault with blunt weapons
encircling the offender or offenders and
shouting loudly for up to 5 minutes and
finally restraint followed by an
instance of scp-2401 nonsensical version
of the right to silence before offender
is physically carried to a location
outside of the view of nearby
individuals or video equipment the
following transcript is a combination of
a portion of confiscated surveillance
footage from Street wails recorded from
1511 to 1515 on April 22nd 2009 and the
cellphone footage and spoken testimony
of a nearby witness and neste sized
after interview begin transcript 1511 22
a civilian is seen sitting on a street
bench and removing his shoes within view
of an instance of a CP 2884 115 11 27 3
instances of scp-2401 approached the
civilian 1511 31 civilian appears to
initially mistake instances of a CP 2884
2 for law enforcement
then inquires as to the purpose of the
cameras on their helmets 15 11 36 two
instances of scp-2401 the civilian while
a third stands facing him
confiscated cell phone footage begins
[Music]
13:53 two instances of scp-2401 into the
alleyway they emerged from one remaining
instance picks up civilian shoes then
stares in the direction of the filming
witness for six seconds before following
neither the SCP 2884 two instances nor
the civilian re-emerge and transcript
[Music]
incident 2880 401 instances of a CP 2884
two are difficult to capture mainly due
to the brevity of their appearances
however on November 2nd 2010 a
foundation rapid response team was able
to apprehend five instances of scp-2401
sin the Greenwich Area London by
unidentified individuals in riot gear
instances offered significant resistance
displaying above normal levels of
physical strength and resistance to
aerosolize sedatives before being
forcibly restrained captive instances
designated SCP 2884 a through e this is
interview 2884 one date November 3rd
2010 interviewer dr. Carlisle subject s
CP 2884 to a playing log now
hello SCP 2842 a may I call you that or
do you have another name any well why
were you near associates assaulting
those people violation of law five one
three eight four no gathering of more
than two individuals is to take place
within eight point four meters of a
birdbath could you explain why that
makes sense to you the law is the law
the other CEO makes the laws it all
makes sense I see
who is this overseer the our CEO makes
the laws
the overseer watches everything alright
and what purpose today's laws serve the
overseer sees a future free of crime
filth and degradation free of corruption
free of chemical addiction free of
littering three of murder free of clay
walking free of rape free of loitering
that's quite enough tell me who does the
overseer see all these things through
the eyes what happened to your eyes CP
2840 a the ones in your skull never had
them don't need them are you sure
because from here without your visor it
look like they've been surgically
removed never had them don't need them
I see no back to this overseer do you
know where he has no PR the seer is
everywhere their eyes to see me overseer
is watching you right now no further
information could be extracted from a CP
2884 to a or b SCP 2884 to a and b
terminate and submitted for autopsy
remaining captive instances transferred
to site o six three
that's what I've been saying this whole
time
security cameras men they're everywhere
I you know what never mind
well never listens to me anyway that
about does it for today thank you all
for listening if indeed you still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Muslim Mookie slump god
Justin day Jono Porter
captain Gorge fluffy bread my archive
curator Nick Tiber ball Judi Dench
cheese whip dips McGee an oblong dish
boy
if you would like a special Thank You
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the hogan
thank you
you